You decided to build your own simple
agent loop, just 100 lines, no need for
LangGraph. Six weeks later, you're
staring at 2,000 lines of retry logic,
state handling, and approval gates you
didn't plan to write. Congrats, you've
just built a shittier version of the
exact [music] framework you swore off,
and now you're the only person that
understands it.
>> [music]
>> Most often, a small loop is the answer
for what you need. Sometimes, it's good
to reach for the framework after all.
Here's what you're building, stripped to
the metal. You send the model two
things: the user's request and a list of
tools it's allowed to call. Each one
just a name and the arguments [music] it
takes. The model replies. If it's a
normal answer, you're done. If it's a
request to use a tool, your code runs
that tool, takes [music] whatever comes
back, and pastes it onto the end of the
conversation. Then you send the whole
thing again. Call the model, run a tool,
[music] append the result, repeat until
it stops asking or you make it stop.
>> [music]
>> It's maybe 100 lines without a library.
You've heard the line, "An agent is just
a while loop," 100 times by [music] now.
What's more interesting is how it holds
up in production.
So, what does a framework like LangGraph
or Crew AI do for you on top of that?
Strip the marketing and it's four jobs.
It writes your boilerplate, defining and
parsing tools. It manages state, your
history, your memory, your checkpoints.
It handles orchestration, the routing
between steps. And it runs operations,
the retries, the logging, the
guardrails. There's no hidden
intelligence in there that your loop
doesn't have. Every one of those four
jobs is code you could write yourself.
The question is whether you should hand
that part over.
>> [music]
>> Hand it over and you get speed, a
working agent on day one with a stack of
nasty problems pre-solved. The cost is
visibility. Your prompts, your tool
calls, the exact text the model sees,
all of it slides one layer back behind
the framework's code,
>> [music]
>> where you can't watch it as closely. And
this isn't a hot take from a forum.
Anthropic's own guide on building agents
warns that frameworks can hide the
prompts and responses [music] underneath
and make the thing harder to debug. The
company that makes the models is telling
[music] you to go easy on the
abstractions. The framework people
weren't wrong to build these. Back in
2023, they were fixing a real problem.
>> [music]
>> The models were bad at this. Ask one for
a clean block of JSON to trigger [music]
a tool and it might wrap it in chatter,
misspell a key, forget an argument, or
smother it in markdown that broke your
parser. [music]
So, the early frameworks became
scaffolding. They forced the output into
shape, retried it when it came back
malformed, and covered for everything
the model couldn't do alone.
But then, the models got good.
Tool calling went from a prompt
engineering trick to a native feature
the providers built in. Context windows
grew big enough to hold a long task
without clever memory hacks, and the
models got better at planning several
steps ahead on their own. A lot of what
those frameworks did for a living the
model now just does. One of Anthropic's
own agents used a trick that reset the
context at a certain point. It [music]
clearly helped an older model stay on
track. Move to a newer, stronger model
and that same trick became, in their
words, dead weight. The help had turned
into a drag. The scaffolding you built
for last year's model can become the
thing holding this year's model back.
So, you start simple, the way everyone
says to. A working while loop with a few
tool calls, you bring it to production.
First, it crashes. [music]
45 steps into a 50-step job, the network
flips. The process dies and your agent
has total amnesia because the entire
history was sitting in memory that just
evaporated.
>> [music]
>> So, you add a way to save state to disk
after every step. Then, it starts
burning money. It gets stuck hunting for
something that isn't there, runs the
same dead end 20 [music] times, and you
find out from the bill. So, you add a
spend cap and a hard limit on steps.
>> [music]
>> Then, a second user shows up and their
conversation bleeds into the first one's
because your one history array assumed
one person at a time.
>> [music]
>> So, you add sessions. Then, you give it
a tool that can delete things and you
really don't want the model deciding by
itself when to pull that trigger. So,
you [music] add an approval gate. A
human signs off before it runs.
Look at what you're holding now. State
persistence, budget control, sessions,
an approval gate, routing. It's the
accidental framework. Nearly every team
that swears off frameworks ends up
writing a worse one.
Now, look back at the very first wall
you hit, the crash. It had nothing to do
with the model being smart or dumb. It
was about whether your run could survive
being interrupted. [music]
And surviving a crash, then picking up
where you left off without redoing
expensive work, is one of the oldest
problems in plain distributed [music]
systems. It predates AI by decades. So,
to fix it, you don't reach up for an
agent framework, you reach down for a
durable runtime underneath your loop.
Temporal, D Bosch, Ingest. You keep your
plain loop exactly as it is, run it on
one of these, and when the server
reboots mid-task, it resumes from the
line where it died with every variable
intact. Anthropic hit the same wall
building their research agents and set
it straight. Agents are stateful,
[music] errors pile up, and restarting
from scratch is brutally expensive. So,
they built systems to resume [music]
instead. This is why loop versus
framework is a little bit the wrong
fight. For a lot of teams, the real
first upgrade lives underneath the loop
in a durable runtime, not in a framework
bolted on top. Temporal raised $300
betting that's where the real pain
lives.
There's one more upgrade people grab way
too early, the multi-agent swarm. A team
[music] of specialist agents, a
researcher handing to a writer handing
to an editor, all chattering [music] at
each other. It sounds great, it mostly
isn't. Even AI swarm vendors warn you
about it. Cognition, a company whose
whole product is a multi-agent AI
engineer, wrote one of the most cited
essays in the space, and the gist of the
title is, "Don't build multi-agents."
Anthropic, who published a glowing
success story about a multi-agent system
of their own, lands in the same spot.
[music]
They both trace the problem back to
context, not to the number of agents.
Split a job across a researcher, writer,
and an editor, and every handoff is a
chance to drop information. Agent one
summarizes its work a little badly.
Agent [music] two builds on the gap, and
the mistakes compound down the line like
a game of telephone. Add more agents,
mostly you add more telephone. The swarm
is what you use for work that's truly
parallel and mostly reading rather than
writing.
>> [music]
>> Where you fan out, gather a lot at once,
and pull it back together. The second
your agents have to share context or
make decisions that lean on each other,
one capable agent with a big context
window tends to beat the whole
committee. So, where does this leave you
building your first real agent? The
[music] honest path is boring, and it
runs in order. Start with the loop, one
model, [music] a couple of tools, a cap
on steps so it can't spin forever. Get
it working on real tasks before [music]
you add anything. You'll learn more
about how your agent really breaks in 1
week of that [music] than in a month of
framework tutorials.
Then add structure only when you smack
into a specific wall and fit [music] the
fix to the wall. Bury it in boilerplate
for type tools, pull in a small library
like by dentic AI, not a whole
framework. Need strict auditable
branching where this step must always
run before that one. That's where a
graph framework like LangGraph is worth
it. [music]
Crashes losing work, runs lasting hours,
that's a durable runtime, temporal or
Dboss. Multi-agent comes dead last and
only for that narrow parallel read heavy
case. There's a clean signal for when
you've outgrown the loop. The day
debugging a failed run takes longer than
just shipping the feature would have,
your hand-rolled loop has turned into
its own little platform
>> [music]
>> and a real framework is probably cheaper
than babysitting it. Remember, almost
everyone shouting in this debate has
something to sell. The framework company
has a course and a cloud plan.
>> [music]
>> The runtime startup has a $300 million
round to earn out. Half the loudest
anti-framework voices are shipping an
SDK with their own name on it. This
video has nothing for you to buy except
for a free subscribe. Start with the
loop, build the accidental framework
just far enough to feel which wall you
hit first, then go get the one piece
that fixes [music] the wall and not a
piece more.
>> [music]